denise filiatrault vous êtes en pleine
répétition de la pièce adieu monsieur à
fonds marins peuvent être présentées ici
au théâtre du rideau vert fait attendre
c'est votre dernière mise en scène
non non non ces jeunes à risque parce
que ça fait j'espère bien faire une
autre à la fin de la saison 6 de
situation change si la coved et des
frais c'est qu'on ne peut pas voir plus
que tant de personnes à la salle se
ferait pas pourrait pas la faire parce
que ça coûte trop
après ce bref j'ai peut-être trop
vieilles ou serait plus dur pour la fête
mais pourquoi vous arrêter en si bon
chemin
écoutez j'ai 89 ans ma voix 90's à mon
avis je pense qu'ils étaient algériens
bieber katy ce qu'elle voit ça na li à
la hausse port il faut pour faire les
fous très belle agréable de faire du
théâtre pgd bij fatigué j'ai 89 ans je
peux mettre un frein comme ce l'était à
5 4 ça cartonne chaque corps comme une
jeune fille de vetter mais plus
maintenant
vous avez commencé votre carrière dans
un monde d'hommes
je te dise oui pour une femme de
l'époque surtout remonter mais j'étais
pas très bon il faut dire que je
chantais dans maison chez nous pour mes
amis puis j'avais décidé de faire des
concours d'amateurs ajoute encore km
pour les concours de matam et j'arrivais
jamais première toujours 2e
à votre époque vous êtes en battant
parce que j'ai madame jean louis audet y
avait rien à toi pas déconner tu vas pas
y aller je mange à l'iodé parce que mes
parents m'ont pesant que ça donne t'as
pas besoin sur soi faire autre chose
soit faire du sénat grâce à l'accord
officiel vous avez votre diplôme oui
vous aurez perdu votre pas ben oui à ce
qui était une école pour moins de bois
d'école je pense c'est mon mari jacques
labbé qui m'a beaucoup appris et que
j'ai écouté parce que moi douze journées
on parlait pas de ça ça n'existe pas pas
rappelez-vous j'ai 89 ans à l'époque
j'avais 10 ans 11 12 13 14 ans on le
voit blanche un jeune est mort c'est
merveilleux ce qui donnerait du web en
se déguisant pour paraître plusieurs
ponts entre evrard le seul président
c'est très spécial qu'on se retrouve ici
au théâtre du rideau vert parce que sur
cette scène en 1968 il avait un carnet
rose ou mi-mai dans les bonnes soeurs de
michel tremblay c'est une pièce qui a
vraiment changé votre vie de quelle
façon selon vous la villette d'artistes
en tout cas parce que à l'époque aux
besoins des pièces françaises avec
terres sont français on ne peut pas
jouer secte accent québécois parce que
j'avais ça n'avait aucun sens
ç'a changé mon quartier je suis amusé à
jouer dos de gens de pièces après a
autant que je serai beaucoup tremblé
côté bijoux l'aimé d'un amour infini oui
oui oui et dossiers même piège france je
pense que vous vous entendez bien vous
avez tous les deux du plateau mont royal
c'est ça au scanner on est des milieux
presqu'en même temps avec ton disant
différent celui qui est présenté moi
mais quand même c'est impossible de le
résumer en cinq minutes une carrière de
75 ans mais parmi vos grosses séries
télé je pense aux belles histoires des
pays d'en haut il ya six mois et loto
chez denis
oui mais pour vous quel était votre rôle
le plus marquant
je sais pour fne demandé au public
moi je sais quoi moi j'en parlais cette
entrevue le pendant un mois et l'autre
c'est mythique label est interdite on a
lancé un style de situation je comprends
que nos personnages étaient sûrs qu'on
fait soi cabaret les locaux blanc et
l'auguste le les méchants et puis la
bonne fille des cliniques un bac à petit
parce que ce que j'ai les riches il
représentait c'était pas ça du tout puis
dominique récente épopée moi non plus je
l'aimé pour que ce qu'on fait parce
qu'on fait au cabaret en tout contre
ouvrit situation pour le faire pour le
prg pour les jouer
on les a trouvés mais au fait rage et
les accepter moi je voulais diriger je
voulais travailler derrière dirigez vous
avez dit que vous avez un petit côté
boss des bécosses oui et même dans votre
biographie ou deux pages de 120 que
certaines personnes trouvent que c'est
difficile de travailler avec vous moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est un
personnage que vous vous êtes donné une
forme de carapaces et c'est plus il fera
parce que le personnage ou même car à
peine je sais pas je sais pas j'ai pas
pu être qu'est la passe des fois c'est
peut-être parce que j'ai peur alors la
peur me fait très exigeante
il faut que ça marche il faut que je
réussisse parce que j'ai pas tranquille
m'engager il est propriétaire ou
copropriétaire le théâtre il va perdre
des sous j'étais dessus comme ça - faut
pas faux que sa barge focal du monde
alors c'est peut-être pour ça que je
suis exigeante j'ai pas toujours été un
honnête je pense oui mais pas toujours
je l'appelle méchaal entendu que c'était
pas volontaire mais après quand on me
dit oh mon dieu c'est pouvant atteindre
ce qu'on dit wak oo prêts non mais oui
fait à temps sur mes enfants c'est maman
j'ai tant appris
quand tu es l'un juin non nous donne
même pas comme ceux de la presse c'est
fini c'est sûr mais elle est beaucoup
question à mr pression compris des
affaires que danny flynn trop je vous
dis le mot de cambronne pour la suite et
pour votre rentrée au théâtre du rideau
vert
j'avais ce pas merci mais vous savez que
je vous aime je pense que vous le savez
vraiment oui ben oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]